all right the David Pakman show is going
on summer vacation I wanted to tell
everybody since we do have nearly 400
thousand subscribers on YouTube now I
don't want anybody to think we've gone
off the air we do plan our vacations
ahead of time it's really important for
staff to get breaks but we do take it
seriously we have created a whole bunch
of extra new exclusive content for the
YouTube channel which will be published
during the vacation we've got forum lot
for a long-form investigative type
videos that will be coming out one on
classical liberalism one about voter
fraud and voter suppression one about
the myth of the violent left another
debunking the idea that socialism has
never worked and that that is going to
be very exciting but the show is not
going anywhere Pat we're just going on
vacation we will be back and we take
this seriously enough that we are we've
got several dozen news clips and stories
that we'll be publishing to YouTube
during our vacation we're actually not
even here right now I mean you're in
Argentina I'm on a cross-country
roadtrip it's like this is prerecorded
for sure yeah it's crazy what's going on
and we'll edit that out though so people
don't know I will live stream if major
news breaks I will have my microphone
with me and I will have my camera with
me so if Trump is impeached or we go to
war with North Korea or I don't know
what I will be able to livestream and
then we'll be back and it should be
really not major drama and people have
said you know David Dave Rubin announced
that he's completely going off the grid
for all of August and are you
coordinating your vacation with Dave
Rubin I think it's just vacations or
common in August all right I think
there's a number of shows that are going
to be on vacation upcoming and back in I
don't remember what might happen last
summer I hadn't spoken to Sam cedar
who's a friend of mine for a while and
it turned up that we were both going to
be away the exact same 10-day period I
don't know if it was July or when it was
last year but I think it's just a common
vacation time that's what it is
people think that there's some
conspiracy where you're going to join up
together and hang out in the middle of
nowhere
right that would be kind of weird that
would be crazy that would be crazy so we
are on vacation but it's not really
going to affect you in that we're going
to have a ton of great new content but
we may not be responding to the breaking
news of every single day
and that's okay because we're on
vacation
but we'll be back I wonder which random
celebrity Donald Trump is going to
attack on Twitter inevitably in the time
that we're gone I know it's going to be
tough not to see that but hopefully week
when we can at least recover from
missing that that type of breaking news
but seriously if you're also on vacation
during August we will talk to you when
we get back it has been a great 2017 so
far approaching four hundred thousand
subscribers and we've got membership
going and patreon and all this different
stuff and we're going to keep it going
when we return